Um,
so I guess what I'll do today is talk a little bit about the fall of communism.
It's,
it's hard to believe because,
uh,
you know,
all that happened and now it's already,
next year will be the 20th anniversary of the fall of the wall.
And,
uh,
it,
and,
and you guys were not born yet.
A few of you are,
some of you were born in 1990.
Is that possible?
Were you born in 1990 some of you in 1990 way that,
see,
that's after the wall fell.
I can remember seeing the on TV,
the,
you know,
the sort of quick trial is to chest cues and them being gunned down in the,
in the garden behind behind their house.
And they are really a nasty,
nasty pair.
But,
um,
the whole thing is now it seems like old history.
So I want to talk a little bit about that and then talk about kind of chow
global challenges and,
and themes that we've talked about.
You know,
uh,
now we,
we,
we talk about immigration,
we talk more about globalization,
but I'll talk a little bit about that too.
So,
um,
uh,
let's do that.
And then,
then,
uh,
then we're out.
We're out of here.
Um,
so,
uh,
again,
this is,
it seems like this is history.
Some of you here,
it's not history at all,
is something that you all we all live through and in a way anticipated and then,
uh,
saw developing,
I mean,
we're in France when all that was happening and just listening on the radio and
BBC and all this stuff really quite amazing.
Well,
um,
the big difference,
of course,
that made possible,
uh,
the dramatic dramatic changes that happen in,
in Europe between 1990 and eastern Europe between 1989 in 1992 must begin with
a,
with a guy who,
uh,
you know,
independent of the fact that,
that the soil system just didn't work.
But with a guy who's,
who's,
who's declining reputation in,
in Russia,
uh,
I find just incredible.
And that's Mikhail Gorbachev.
Um,
who,
you know,
it was relegated a few years ago.
He actually did.
And TV ad for Burger King,
uh,
you know,
at that point,
because he needed the money and,
and his sort of fall,
the fall of his,
of his image in,
in,
uh,
in the former Soviet Union and Russia.
I find that extraordinarily hard to,
uh,
to match.
And because it made all the difference in the world that when people in Hungary
and in,
in Czechoslovakia,
which then split between the Czech Republic and Slovakia,
uh,
and in Poland where,
and in other places,
but mostly those three places,
when they began to push for reforms and they decided that they wanted to reform
communism and they didn't want even communism at all.
The big difference was in 1953 when there were riots in,
uh,
in Berlin and East Berlin.
And I,
and I'm old enough to remember,
you know,
crossing the border,
uh,
the wall in East Berlin,
you know,
they were squished like grapes.
And in 1968 when,
when Dube,
uh,
who ends up basically what janitorial duties after that,
when do cha dupe check?
Tried to put a human face on communism and reformed communism.
There were,
there were as,
as the expression goes,
tanks before tea time,
the Soviet tanks rolled in,
um,
and,
and squished them to like grapes and they had their martyrs and Wenceslaus
square one guy burned himself to death.
And it's still,
uh,
in protest,
it's still a memory,
uh,
in bedded in the collective memory of that place.
But there was a big difference.
There was a big,
big difference and that Gorbachev made clear that there wouldn't be tanks before
tea time.
And when he went to Berlin and when he went to Prague and his name became a sign
of protest,
when they're chanting Gorbey Gorbey,
they're chanting for the demands of,
of reform in their own,
in their own states.
And when the various groups had been meeting off and on,
particularly in Poland and Hungary,
uh,
were,
were dissidents was most developed and where there was an alternate kind of
sieve,
civic societies or civic space develop,
uh,
the Gore B's name had become symbolic with a possibility of change.
And he made clear that there weren't going to be tank sat in.
And at that point,
these,
these huge changes were inevitable.
But these changes in,
in,
in eastern Europe and the former satellite states really were facilitated,
were accentuated,
were made inevitable by the fact that communism didn't work.
That's a lie in the Soviet Union,
that the client lines were longer and longer.
There was more a concern,
more attention to consumer goods,
but also that Gorbachev was a very different leader.
Gorbachev was,
uh,
was the educated unlike Brezhnev,
her who was as extremely elderly,
a predecessor,
he could give a speech without,
uh,
you know,
reading an off note cards.
Well,
Ronald Reagan really couldn't either,
but,
uh,
Gorbachev would,
was compelling.
He was smart.
He was educated.
He understood the system.
He'd come up through the system and he was committed to change.
But until the very end,
even when they kind of kidnap him,
not kind of,
they kidnapped him and he's held under house arrest in,
in,
uh,
in Crimea.
He stuck until the end with the belief that communism could be reform and that
you could put a human face.
Allah Dube check.
He didn't look to Jude.
Jude checked as a model,
but on communism and until the very end,
I mean,
he,
he believed that you could have,
have communism that this good idea gone terribly wrong.
Uh,
that could be,
could be reforma.
So he was very,
very different than his predecessors.
Crew chef has often been,
has been underappreciated.
I mean,
Khrushchev,
after all,
you know,
did come out against it against Stalinism,
uh,
in the famous party congress and,
and,
and all of that and were crucial.
And Khrushchev was a very wily,
a guy who knew a lot about agriculture.
And,
and in some ways it was a compelling a character,
but then his disappearance,
uh,
in 1964,
isn't that when crew,
chef Louis power in 1964,
he was followed by a couple of really orthodox style Indians,
uh,
and Gorbachev's rise,
really,
uh,
must be seen in that context.
Uh,
Gorbachev was born in southern Russia in 1931.
He worked his way up as you had to in the Party organization,
or you studied law at the University of Moscow and he knew the West and
respected many things about the west.
He also knew,
uh,
well how just devastating Stalinism had been for his own country.
Both his grandfathers had been arrested on a false charges when he was a boy.
He was very talented.
He knew how to manipulate the system,
and he becomes a secretary of the communist central committee.
And,
and,
and like crew chef before,
uh,
in his,
origins,
he was responsible for,
for Soviet,
uh,
agriculture,
agriculture.
And unlike his predecessors,
really including crew chef,
he was less as an a phobic.
He did,
he had less of this suspicion of,
of,
uh,
of non Russians in the Soviet Union was dominated by Russia.
Uh,
let us,
uh,
leave,
no doubt about that.
Um,
and,
and so he believed that the communist dream had been destroyed by Stalin,
Islam,
and by the rigidity of the structure and by the inability to enact serious
economic reforms.
And the Soviet Union like the other powers,
uh,
had simply miserable economies,
miserable economic situations,
the satellite,
the European satellites,
uh,
Eastern European satellite states,
in many ways a victimized by unfavorable,
uh,
economic arrangements with the Soviet Union who exploited them.
But nonetheless,
they were,
they were able to,
to,
uh,
be kept afloat by,
by,
uh,
um,
by the Soviet Union.
And so he embraces the really only two terms that are,
that I didn't send these out,
uh,
but,
to,
to be remembered,
I suppose in one is the policy of liberalization,
which is called glasnost openness in government combined with a greater degree
of free expression.
He takes people who were liberals,
who are real reformers,
not just party hacks.
And it gives them positions of responsibility.
Um,
and he realized that,
look,
if you live in northern Russia,
you can see finished television.
Uh,
you know,
if you live in Astonia,
you can,
where the language is somewhat similar to,
to finish that and most difficult to languages,
you can,
you can see what's going on in these images of,
uh,
as an East Berlin,
the images of,
of,
of West Berlin,
and,
uh,
of,
of a different way of life.
And,
and,
and it's,
you can't simply pretend that there wasn't a better way of life for many people.
Uh,
you know,
there are lots of people in the,
in,
in the former Soviet Union may have had their doubts within the following 10
years about the kind of runaway bandit capitalism,
you know,
high crime capitalism,
the developed in,
in,
uh,
in Russia and is victimized Russia and Bulgaria in particular,
and other places as well.
But he,
he spoke openly,
publicly about the failings of the system.
And that was the hush hush word.
You didn't talk about the failings of the system.
You're always talking about the radiant future.
Remember the radiant future,
but the future wasn't radio.
There were long lines.
It just simply didn't work.
And he realized that,
that,
you know,
if you're going to supply the cities with consumer goods,
you have to return to the free market.
You really have to return to the old,
uh,
you know,
new economic policy.
Well,
you know,
but you already know about [inaudible] and the early,
uh,
in the early 1920s.
Um,
and he also,
the second is parish troika,
the restructuring of,
of the whole system,
uh,
with the belief that he had that communism could remain responsible to the
desires of,
of ordinary people,
of ordinary people in this,
in the Soviet republic.
He said,
uh,
and he could toss off a memorable phrases very easily.
He was extremely bright guy.
Still very much alive.
We need a revolution of the mind that you had to come to recommence wasn't
whole.
You had to begin from,
from the beginning and reconstruct,
uh,
this,
this reformed communism that would be responsive to ordinary people.
Now,
it didn't work out the way he thought it was going to work out.
The entire system collapsed.
Uh,
and three things,
three things made this a possible,
the fall of communism in the Soviet Union and in eastern and central Europe.
First within all of these states,
but most notably the Baltic states and where people held hands,
they formed a human chain all the way across Lithuania,
Latvia,
and Estonia,
holding hands,
a human chain across the entire Baltic region that these places had strong
nationalist movements such as the Lithuanian movement that we discussed earlier.
And these continued,
uh,
but,
also in eastern Europe,
particularly in Hungary,
uh,
and in Poland,
but,
but also in Ukraine,
remember,
Ukraine needs a different language.
It's a related but different language.
There's still huge problems because so many,
uh,
Russian still live in Ukraine.
And,
and,
and we don't have time to talk about the ethnic complexities of these region.
I mean,
the Russians who were left in Latvia where there were the greatest,
the more Russians were in Latvia than an Estonia or Lithuania.
I mean,
faced all sorts of,
of discrimination.
And,
and this is a problem.
But anyway,
these cultural demands,
these nationalistic demands could not be placated by,
talk about a reform communism because in the Soviet Union,
uh,
the idea that the republics were equal was a sheer myth.
And the idea that,
that,
that there would be no tolerance to toleration of,
of,
uh,
of different ways of looking at the world.
Uh,
basically,
um,
there was some showcase a stuff about the flowering of the cultures,
but it was basically myth,
uh,
secondly,
in,
in 1989 in these countries,
uh,
amid economic crisis,
the great horrors of,
of deprivation,
the long lines of people wearing thread bare coats,
uh,
waiting for trams,
that were late,
uh,
a reform movement,
a politically democratic movement emerges in all of these states.
Uh,
in Russia.
It was led by the Nobel prize winning physicist to Andres,
uh,
a soccer off who would help develop of all things a high hydrogen bomb.
Um,
and then whereas the works of social needs and social needs and whose vision you
have to celebrate,
you have to separate Solzhenitsyn's a critique of the gulag from his vision of,
I mean,
of the return of the czar or whatever,
but social needs and used to run into them here in Sterling Memorial Library.
He was here for a year or two,
working in the stacks and the,
and the collection there,
but social needs and where's before,
uh,
his,
his stuff on,
on,
uh,
on the Gulag was passed from hand to hand.
You know,
typescripts past,
secretly from hand to hand.
Uh,
you,
you could suddenly,
uh,
you,
you could read it.
Uh,
you could read the social needs and on a,
what was the increasingly,
uh,
no longer hidden secret of,
of the Gulag and what happened to people sent to the Gulag.
And so these dissidents begin to reach an increasing audience within all of
these countries,
with all of the Soviet republics and in the United States.
You know,
Gorbachev came to,
comes to Washington DC in the mall and he scares the hell,
uh,
in a country I that had,
had political assassinations.
You will remember this one out of those people who are supposed to protect them
cause he leaves,
he leaves the limousine and he'd go plunges into the crowd and gives the Russian
equivalent of a high fives and shake hands with people.
And they were just scared to death.
I mean,
someone's going to blow him away.
And he charms the Reagans.
Uh,
and of course his intellectual capacity was many times,
uh,
those folks.
Uh,
but I mean he says the interest,
I shouldn't have capacity,
his interest,
but he charms people because he was at,
he was a real live functioning,
you know,
intellectual in politics,
committed,
obviously committed and putting his reputation and putting the whole,
the whole estate on the line.
And so this was the second thing.
And third,
it was the accentuation acceleration of this political,
I mean,
of this economic crisis,
things weren't getting better.
Poland is a great example of that.
The reason the solidarity starts in 1980 and in ship yards of Gdansk is bizarre
to go back there.
They're probably going to close.
There's a huge pictures of the pope all over the place,
but it's still as a site of memory.
Uh,
when you go to Gdansk,
uh,
and the reason that solidarity starts with Lech Walesa and not just alone in my
friends in Poland who are a little bit younger than [inaudible] and lots of
other people,
is because there wasn't enough to eat you in a terrible situation.
So they unionized.
I said,
we're going to put forth our claims like unions had done in France and in Italy
and in Spain and other places.
Uh,
and they,
or as people had wanted to do when the early days of the Soviet regime and they
had been squished like grapes.
Everybody's been squished like grapes,
but it be the economic crisis makes these three things merge.
National Democratic nationalists,
democratic reform,
and the desire for economic change.
And so you've got this charming man who it takes big time decisions.
I,
lots of Jews,
for example,
wanting to leave the Soviet Union and they were victimized by antisemitism
there.
Uh,
they were often treated as second class citizens.
And Gorbachev says,
finally,
he says,
yes,
you can immigrate,
you can go to Israel,
United States.
And so things change.
There's palpable change and people have a sense of,
of that what's going to happen,
uh,
that,
that new things are,
uh,
going to,
going to occur.
And the speed with which this happened took a western leaders by surprise.
They weren't not Satcher that's a good example.
I mean,
they,
they were not ready for the speed of,
of which these,
uh,
the,
these,
these changes were coming.
And so when people are shouting Gorbey Gorbey Gorbey,
uh,
the subtext is,
is that we want the reforms in Hungary,
in Poland,
uh,
in,
in checklist Slovakia and in other countries as well.
But the movements were much smaller in Bulgaria or in Romania,
which was under the police state of,
of chess queue in the same situation in Albania,
that kind of the cult of whole Chai who was very tied to the,
to the,
uh,
to,
to communist China,
uh,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
And He makes clear in straws book,
in a speech to the Council of Europe.
And in July,
1989 that he rejects the Brezhnev doctrine.
Uh,
you know,
his predecessor Leonid Brezhnev,
that the Soviet Union as a 1953 and as of 1968 or 1956 in hunger.
I remember when it was a really little kid.
I remember,
you know,
Hungarian,
uh,
children who've been lucky enough to escape the,
the revolution,
uh,
coming to Ainsworth's school and in Portland,
Portland,
Oregon.
He said,
any interference in domestic affairs and any attempts to restrict the
sovereignty of states,
both friends and allies or any others are inadmissible.
Um,
and the,
the Gorbachev says that these movements in Hungary,
in Poland,
that they are inspiring.
He found them personally,
personally inspiring.
And so the,
the rest,
as they say is,
is,
I mean it is history.
Uh,
you've all seen images of,
of the wall,
first of,
of,
of young students your age,
your age,
putting flowers into the guns of the,
of the vocal who are the east German guards,
flowers in the guns.
And then you,
the whole goddamn thing just collapses this.
Suddenly people are pouring over the wall.
Uh,
people on trains are,
are,
uh,
and the East German government.
Hanukkah was one of the very,
very worst of all of them.
And he's really just awful.
And Staci,
uh,
infiltrated almost every,
every organization.
There's a great movie called the lives of others.
Uh,
a great,
great movie that I say,
if this course went this far,
I would recommend you see the lives of others about spying and,
and,
and integrity and just all sorts of things.
And,
you know,
in a hundred Acre was saying,
give these people,
return them to East Germany and the Hungarian say,
no,
we won't return them to East Germany.
And they start taking around the,
the,
the barbwire borders around their own country.
And the whole thing just happens like that,
you know,
within,
within the Berlin Wall collapses and with a,
you know,
a month,
within a month,
the [inaudible].
So for better,
for worse,
our have been gunned down in,
in,
uh,
in a garden after a very hasty televised,
trauma.
They're very big,
very bad people.
There's no doubt about it,
but they,
there was no due process but that,
but,
uh,
um,
that was the end of that.
And Honecker whose slogan was always forward,
never backward.
I mean,
until the very end,
he was,
he was in the Czech leaders,
very much the same.
And,
and the,
and a Bulgarian and Romanian leaders in Albanian leaders way,
Albania is a case of part.
Uh,
we're,
we're going to hold the,
keeps the whole thing,
uh,
alive.
Uh,
the,
the whole communist system was going to,
um,
uh,
going to survive,
no matter what.
And of course it didn't work out that way.
And checklists.
EVOC Kia,
uh,
the group of writers and intellectuals,
so don't,
don't,
uh,
um,
Havo,
uh,
you know,
who had signed charter 77 and,
and we're,
we're put in,
in jail as a result of that who demanded reform.
You already had in Czechoslovakia,
uh,
and in,
in Poland and in Hungary,
you already had intellectuals who are anticommunist or who reforming communists
meeting sometimes very openly.
And so in these countries that transition to democracy or to parliamentary rule
would be easier because the passing of the torch was easier in Czechoslovakia.
You know,
there were some parliamentary antecedents.
Uh,
Poland also did,
ah,
Hungary,
less so,
but you had this sort of flourishing,
uh,
alternative civil society that had been in developing.
And so the passing of,
of the,
to the new generation,
despite all the economic problems and despite the ethnic tensions that would
remain,
was much easier than it would be in,
uh,
in,
um,
in Bulgaria for example,
in Bulgaria,
what the leadership does a,
they feel cornered.
So they tried to accentuate anti Turkish feeling cause or many Turks lived in
Bulgaria.
And so they,
lots of Turks flee and then they go to Turkey.
In fact,
they find the thing that things are worse in Turkey and made them go back to
Bulgaria,
uh,
that are in the con,
the problem of the tensions between the Romanians and the Hungarians in Romania
helps generate change reform because outside of Bucharest,
the big calls for reform and the organization,
uh,
is the work of Hungarians who are living in the Hungarian parts of Romania.
But you have the transition to parliamentary regime.
We much harder,
uh,
in those places.
The case of Bulgaria is,
is particularly interesting.
And it's also when I know the last about least about,
because they've just had a,
you know,
essentially the change is so slow in many ways of coming in a,
of,
of happening and,
and the,
the,
the kind of a bandit cessation or the kind of,
uh,
the sort of infiltration of major crime networks in Bulgaria really continued to
run the show.
And you found that to an extent,
and it's,
everybody knows in,
in Russia.
But that's another,
uh,
that's,
that's another case.
So the velvet revolution occurs in,
in a,
um,
uh,
a curves and Chekhov in Texas,
Slovakia.
And,
uh,
where the entire politburo that is the ruling,
group,
uh,
resigned on November 19th of 1989.
I mean,
this is just a matter of,
of a,
a short period of time after the Berlin Wall,
essentially a goes down.
And so,
um,
one of the interesting things about all of this is that it,
that despite the ethnic tensions,
huge ethnic tensions,
uh,
in many of these places that you didn't have the kind of awful bloodbath that
you would have in ex Yugoslavia,
uh,
which was primarily the work of the Serbs,
in those,
in those horrible,
horrible wars that began a bloodletting,
ethnic cleansing,
mass murder,
uh,
eh,
is a less fancy way of,
of putting a thin ethnic cleansing,
uh,
that,
for example,
where there you'd all these tensions between poles and Ukraine because the parts
of eastern Poland had passed back and forth.
And,
and,
uh,
lots of Ukrainians live in,
in that part of Poland.
And lots of polls live near level often in,
in Ukraine.
And,
and it actually,
uh,
you didn't have the,
and for all of those,
of persecution of,
of Russians,
ethnic Russians living in Latvia above all,
but also an h in Estonia and Lithuania,
you'd really didn't have the kinds of massacres that happened in,
in,
uh,
that,
that happened in,
in,
in ex Yugoslavia.
And one of the reasons for the two reasons for that a one is because of the,
the ethnic religious complexity,
uh,
in that,
the massacres were primarily perpetuated against Muslims of,
by Orthodox,
uh,
Serbs who were inspired by one of the real villains of,
of the last century or any century Slobodan Milosevic who died during his trial
in The Hague,
uh,
who kept talking about a Greater Serbia to include Kosovo,
to include everywhere else.
And also on a more minor,
minor scale,
those carried out,
uh,
by some Croatians,
again against Muslims,
uh,
and all that.
So that,
that was,
uh,
you know,
one,
uh,
a major reason why you didn't have that same thing.
That is,
uh,
the religious difference.
Uh,
and secondly is that in Ukraine,
nobody was really talking about greater Ukraine.
Uh,
and people in Poland,
we're talking about greater Poland imagining.
And next thing you know,
anybody that they can possibly do other way Hitler had done,
or the way the Molossia fits,
Sha perpetuated his,
his sleazy career,
uh,
as leader of,
of the Yugoslav and then Serb a communist party by,
uh,
by giving inflammatory speeches in,
in Kosovo,
uh,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
So the whole thing,
uh,
classes.
Um,
and of course this doesn't,
this doesn't eliminate problems.
If you don't have a real tradition of parliamentary rural,
how do rule,
how do you suddenly have a crate parties that are viable?
How do you create this sort of civic culture?
Uh,
uh,
and know that's not very easy.
And also,
uh,
the Americans prickly from University of Chicago Economics School,
we're giving advice and Poland saying,
you just need an automatic infusion of capitalism that will solve everything.
Well,
that's not what happens at all.
If anything,
it increases the,
the gap between a very rare wealthy people.
A formerly would have been party cadres and the Communist Party and very
ordinary people and everybody,
anyone who follows contemporary Russia now,
uh,
you know,
it was all of that are,
and the code doesn't have a nice,
uh,
you know,
an aggressive go hotel and niece and all these fees,
I should knock them,
go have stayed there in a Yale alumni tour.
But anyway,
uh,
you know,
you find these extraordinarily wealthy,
a Russian billionaire,
so buying up everything and including soccer teams in,
in,
uh,
in Russia,
I mean in,
in,
in England,
uh,
where you still don't have,
um,
I used to be,
there's still people with,
uh,
not enough to eat and other problems.
These ethnic challenges of course,
are nor more graphically and horribly revealed then then in the Balkans.
Uh,
are there other problem of,
of,
you know,
all of these communist systems set above all,
you must have large scale industry,
so they start building is awfully soon out of date factories that,
that the crank out pollution and unimaginable levels.
Uh,
and,
uh,
that one of the effects is,
for example,
the destruction of the black forest.
And,
and in,
uh,
in,
by these clouds of pollution coming from the Czech Republic and,
and,
uh,
to say nothing of the,
of the nuclear,
uh,
you know,
the fact that a lot of the Soviet nuclear installations were in Kazakhstan and
other places and trying to get these diffuse and the mobilized,
particularly when,
uh,
you know,
when the United States now is trying to,
or has been under this last regime has been trying to restart the arms race.
Again,
this is why,
this is a personal comment,
but,
uh,
too bad,
I were talking about how Europeans view,
uh,
view America,
the Americans now have this idea that to put bases in Poland,
uh,
and this is a terrible idea because he's basically going can be transformed into
offensive weapons as well.
And,
and,
uh,
you know,
this can very well as,
as Putin [inaudible],
you know,
at some times,
can't be trusted,
but nonetheless,
it was a vigorous,
aggressive Russia nationalists for better,
for worse,
uh,
that,
that this could,
it could,
it could declension or,
you know,
start again this a unclench on leash,
whatever we call this,
this arms race,
uh,
and the,
and that would be awful.
So there's still lots of problems what will come and say,
ah,
but yet every time I go to Poland,
as I said,
is very frequently now and to other countries.
I mean,
there is just great hope and there wasn't a lot of hope in 1987 or 1986 and
suddenly it was this new,
incredibly transformed,
uh,
world.
Um,
in many places it was easier to tear down to say what you are against that you
didn't want this unreformed communist state or he didn't want communism at all
than it was to sort of miraculously crate this,
this new,
uh,
a new,
a fairer world.
And in Warsaw,
I'm constantly amazed by,
you know,
the,
if you walk war,
so it was completely rebuilt when I was a kid.
I was there and it was,
uh,
you know,
you could,
all you saw was rubble basically.
And now,
you know,
when I walk out of the Hotel Bristol,
a very fancy famous hotel and I turned left,
it looks like the shots of these eight,
you know,
or the roof who,
uh,
San Antonio,
hey in Paris,
all these fancy shops.
And then as we go out to the university,
then you see all these people still wearing the same threadbare quotes,
uh,
waiting in line for the trams as before the communist revolution.
But yet thing things are better.
One of the reasons by the way,
things are better in Poland is that they never did completely collectivized
agriculture at all.
That property,
small,
petite,
appropriate tail,
small,
uh,
units still existed.
Uh,
uh,
and so the transition there was a easy,
easier than other places.
Well,
I mean,
we can say I,
again,
this is what I'm going to say now is how Europeans view,
uh,
you know,
view Europe and also as kind of a European,
I mean,
how they view the United States.
And I might certainly be tempted at the end to talk a little about that and
about human rights,
um,
that,
you know,
we talk about globalization and all of that.
Uh,
uh,
Josie bovie and she was able v lives in Los Angeles for two years.
He's actually a city guy,
but he,
he,
uh,
made his reputation,
in the south of France,
uh,
marching and with tractors,
a blocking,
uh,
French air force installations is trying to keep part of,
of central lowers mass.
He was on trial called Lars Zach from being turned into a,
you know,
for testing,
bomb testing and,
and all that business.
And then he took his campaign against Mcdonald's.
Mcdonald's mcdo became identified with,
uh,
with globalization,
and with Americanization.
So the old kind of anti American sentiment among intellectuals and Josie Bovie
is that when he came to Yale a couple of years ago,
Jim Scott brought him here to Yale.
And,
and actually my daughter took them to Rudy's.
It's what she did.
But what they,
uh,
you know,
when he came here,
he w he came here as sort of a symbol of,
uh,
of antiglobalization.
And you see,
all of,
you seen the images of people in,
in,
uh,
Seattle throwing themselves against the police or against the knees against
police barricades or in Nice or in Italy as well.
And globalization is sort of a catchall.
But if you don't believe that we live in a more global society,
look at the impact of the economic crisis and how quickly that spread,
uh,
within the last two months.
I mean,
we are,
it's an obvious thing that we live in a world where,
you know,
Adidas and all these other shoes and shorts and t shirts or are often outsourced
to two extremely,
the poorest people that can find in Indonesia,
uh,
and other places.
And when you get your phone,
uh,
have some problem with your cell phone.
I still don't have a cell phone or whatever,
but,
uh,
you know,
you're after you'll be ended up talking to somebody in India or Pakistan is as,
as easily are as you are talking to somebody,
uh,
in,
New Jersey.
Um,
and so one aspect of,
of globalization that is so much more visible now than even 15 years ago.
Uh,
and which fits exactly in the,
one of the themes of this course,
of course,
obviously immigration,
uh,
that there are no borders anymore.
Uh,
the creation of the European Union for better or for worse means that you can go
from essentially from Calais all the way to Lithuania and never have your id
check.
Not once I travel on my French id there.
It's only in England and in,
in,
uh,
coming back to United States that you need a passport at all.
But the result is you've got all of these immigrants and you've all seen
pictures of,
of bodies bobbing in the,
in the sea of Moroccans and people from Mali or Tunisia or Senegal trying to get
into Spain.
Because once you got into Spain who essentially made it,
got it made,
uh,
the same passages that Spanish refugees fled,
Franco's terror,
uh,
during and after this,
the,
uh,
the Spanish civil war,
bring people from Mali into France.
Uh,
and of course a female and male sex trafficking from Moldavia in particular from
Bulgaria and from Albania.
Those are the three major points is something that's just just everywhere.
And one of the immigrants are not new.
Uh,
in the 1960s,
these governments said pleased.
They would put,
they put up a science,
please come to work in France,
come to work in Germany,
uh,
in Istanbul have and the,
so many Turks went to Germany.
And then all of a sudden,
you know,
when the bottom of the economy out,
uh,
with,
eh,
the Arab oil embargo in 1973,
1974,
then some of these people who helped make the economy run and who still help
make the economy run,
there's a whole,
you know,
whole,
uh,
underground economy and,
and,
and do jobs at lots of other people then suddenly said,
we don't want them.
And one of the risks,
uh,
that's an obvious grist to anyone who studied in Germany in the 1920s and
thirties,
which you have,
is that economic crisis causes people to escape goat and just stereotyping the
scapegoat.
And in countries like France where the godless made their pact with the devil
and join with the national front and an over the top,
aggressively racist,
a political party whose leader was a torturer,
uh,
John [inaudible] Le Pen in Algeria and,
and who described the Holocaust is a minor detail of world war two,
and who supporters are Nigga the gas he and east to who were negation as to
believe that there wasn't a whole,
the cost,
uh,
when they start their discourse becomes extremely,
extremely,
not only prevalent but acceptable,
then you have a problem even in Switzerland,
uh,
wi which does have a very hard to become resonant switch on,
which does have a large immigrant population.
You had a party of the extreme right in Denmark,
one of the most tolerant places one could ever imagine.
You had one of the most over the top and still have right wing organizations.
Uh,
a hider who just got himself killed in a,
running his car off the road a couple of weeks ago in Austria.
Uh,
you know,
he was unapologetic is probably a bit too strong,
but,
but he,
he,
I said things were much better when the Nazis were in curl the economy.
We didn't have all these other people around.
And that economic crisis and national stereotyping and racism is a recipe for
disaster.
Uh,
and even in countries where democracy really,
really works,
when,
you know,
again,
to return to the case of Poland,
when you have a,
uh,
you have black players being,
being taunted,
uh,
in soccer games.
And Poland is another country's as an in Spain,
one of the worst,
uh,
of a kind of racist baiting a that goes on when,
when,
when these clubs play,
uh,
in France with [inaudible],
Sandra Ma,
uh,
that's another classic example,
or Latino,
which is the Mussolini,
a grand granddaughter's favorite,
uh,
a party and a,
a,
a team in Italy,
then you've got a real problem.
And when it becomes acceptable,
and this is probably,
maybe some of you may consider unfair,
but,
uh,
when suck cuisine president of France,
he's the son of a team of,
of Hungarian immigrants.
And when he borrows the language,
the language of racism,
the language of Lapel Pin,
uh,
to help put them over the top.
And when someone indiviudal Upenn has said,
why do you do so badly in the election?
He said,
and he was right for once.
well,
because they said the same thing as we're saying,
then you've got a problem,
you know,
fortress Europe maybe trying to,
human rights.
Uh,
all these human rights documents give people the right to emigrate,
but not to immigrate.
And how these countries,
including ours,
treat people who are legal immigrants,
those who were illegal immigrants,
uh,
is that a true test of the kinds of values,
that,
uh,
that they have?
And this is an obvious thing to say,
but this,
this is the next,
is the future of this is an ongoing problem,
an ongoing challenge in every single European country,
uh,
that,
toleration.
So civic harmony,
a generosity,
caring,
uh,
in hard times,
is under assault in our country is not,
it has never been immune from that as well.
And this is a,
it's an obvious case,
but it's something that's going to concern people that,
that,
uh,
work on Europe,
look at the role of xenophobia,
uh,
in the rise of the right in the 1920s and above all in the 1930s the same thing
over and over again.
And just to end,
you know,
um,
to end with this,
there's a question of human rights and one of Europeans,
you know,
Europeans had hard time understanding the United States.
They don't understand capital punishment.
They then understand why you can just pick up a gun.
You know,
you can't vote,
but you can buy a machine gun that at some gun gun show almost anywhere you are
north or South and they can't understand that.
But one of the other things they can understand is why in this country we have a
deep abiding institutionalize belief in the right to bear arms,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
But in,
in civic rights are civil rights.
You know,
your,
your rights as defined by being a member of,
of,
you know,
of the state.
But we don't have often not accepted human rights as a category and Europeans
are often just mystified by this.
Let me give you an example that you know that,
again,
this is not politics,
but I can't help saying this said the,
it's very difficult to explain to people how it,
how it is that a United States in the last few years finds itself on a list of
countries that torture not big time,
not Nazi Germany,
not Stalin,
not even the,
not even the level of course.
Pinochet who,
who they tried to extradite and they tried to do everything,
uh,
not in the level of Molossia vets who finally was carted off to,
tribunal,
but the United States in the smirks of President George Bush and Cheney and
these people,
these people put us on the list of tortures and Dif,
Guantanamo that that is an,
that is hurt.
The United States.
The view that people have,
the United States in ways that are simply unimaginable.
That I knew that you can,
these people,
you know,
some,
there are some really bad people.
Other people just got so caught up in the wrong thing.
But even if they're bad people,
they'd never had charges pressed against him.
And you see them when they're in their,
you know,
chained to the ground with their little,
uh,
you know,
orange uniforms and you see the images that they came out of the prisons are,
you have,
you know,
blackwater are these private contractors and gunning down civilians with
impunity.
This stuff didn't use to happen in this country that even during Vietnam.
You know,
when Kelly,
who murdered all those people in Vietnam and you don't remember Vietnam,
Bob and a few others remember Vietnam,
but you know,
he went on trial.
But when states become involved with this,
with kidnapping people off the streets,
uh,
you know,
what do they call it?
And it's secret plane flights,
uh,
to,
to England or to wherever.
This is what made the United States lose so much of its of its,
you'll have its image of,
it's a cla of it's respect.
It's incredible.
I mean,
even in a place that I live with 330 people there and people are not terribly
politicize,
you know,
the politics are still families that are hating each other for generations.
But there is this image of how could this happen?
The United States,
it was always the place that you wanted to go to because things were fair,
things were right.
You know,
I believe nobody asks me,
but since we're talking about the view of,
of Europeans,
you know,
I,
I believe that,
that people like Bush and Cheney to go before the tribunal in The Hague,
if human rights is going to mean anything,
that,
that because there are from the most powerful country in the world,
doesn't mean that they shouldn't face the same kind of standards that you all
believe in.
And it should be that way.
Verner koosh naira is a sort of moderate politician in France.
He's somewhat socialist,
but he's,
he's in the government of,
uh,
of,
of Sarcoma,
of Sarcozi.
And he was the one who helped one of the original creators of mid South San
Frontieres,
Doctors without borders,
you know,
and all these people.
The French,
but not just French Americans and other people.
Many of you may do this,
go off and try to help.
My friend was a physician's assistant,
goes after Guatemala all the time to help people in Nicaragua,
uh,
and,
and cush snare,
you know,
it is a really good guy.
And he's very pro American.
And he said,
this is chilling and ought to be chilling for you.
He said that the magic is done.
The magic is over.
That's exactly what he said.
He said it in English too.
He said,
the magic is over.
What was the magic?
It was what this country rec represents to Europeans.
The magic is over.
And then he paused and he said,
things will never be the same again.
So,
uh,
you know,
I guess just in conclusion that it's up to you to believe in human rights and
believe in the value of people,
whether they're clandestine or are legal immigrants or not.
And that human rights should be written,
uh,
on the face of this country as well.
And that you can return restore that match.